have you turned a blind eye to sleeves
prime minister the pm back on home soil
and familiar ground as he emerges to
confront yet another scandal for number
10.
facing question over what he knew and
when after a point in a former whip now
suspended as a tory mp after accusations
of drunken groping
global price rises but last week's
diplomacy a while away from the
predicament the pm's now in over his
handling of harassment claims we are
facing a domestic economic crisis a
global security crisis and the prime
minister's facing his own political
crisis so can he tell the house what
precisely is his plan
our plan uh is to help the people of
this country as we are with the cost of
living with 1200 pounds coming into
people's bank accounts downing street
insists boris johnson didn't know about
any specific allegations relating to
chris pincher before bringing him into
the fold
but opponents say it's not good enough
and argue this politician shouldn't have
been anywhere near government
the pm claims regarding
chris pincher he wasn't aware of
specific allegations he was aware of
rumors
as a lawyer do you have some sympathy
with that i've got no sympathy with the
prime minister who repeatedly makes bad
judgment calls this is this is not the
first time we're having this discussion
about a prime minister who makes bad
judgment calls he puts himself before
his country so you wouldn't have
appointed chris pincher no i certainly
wouldn't
trying to put clear blue water between
himself and the pm while the labour
leader also trying to distance himself
from his own brexit past the former
figurehead of remain now planting his
flag on tory turf do you rule it out
then return to the single market in your
lifetime
we're not going back we're not going to
rule out
so
you in your lifetime in my lifetime
we're never going back into the european
union beth we're going forward not
backwards we're not reopening those
divisions we've i've ruled it out i
think three times in this instance okay
after a bruising few weeks of
resignation letters and by election
defeats this is another headache boris
johnson could have well done without and
it raises questions again about
leadership in number 10 not just over
the handling of this scandal in recent
days but also over why this mp was put
in that position of power in the first
place and the questions keep coming sky
news understands that carrie johnson
openly questioned the suitability of
chris pincher becoming a whip back in
2017 when she was working for
conservative campaign headquarters boris
johnson then looking increasingly
isolated
in ever thinking that this appointment
was okay at a time when he can ill
afford to alienate any more of his own
mps
surviving tory whips leaving downing
street earlier today trying to get a
grip on the party and shore up the pm
but questions over this saga and boris
johnson's role in it are not going away
beth rigby sky news westminster